vegas le plus qu on vous surnomme
bigoudis à cause de votre calvitie qu'on
imite vos imitations
ou alors que stéphane collaro must be
transforme en crabe rien puce lamamiri
lagaf' rien du tout non vous réagissez
bien le foot et je le trouve plus ou
moins réussies séjour du public qui doit
réagir
je suis plus mal de la saison aura une
opinion mais samedi on croit que
voulez-vous que sa mairie et krasucki
chéché collaro vous trouvez 30
d'après ce que j'ai compris il a voulu
présenter un prolo un métallo par izia
type prime à memni un mégot alors vu un
film comme ça n'a pas d'importance
et puis c'est tout pour le reste bah
c'est son affaire
lui et bigoudis aux policiers ce surnom
aux journées beaucoup de surnoms de
l'année note lakers à 2e surnom très
vite comme ça s'est vu vous avez vu la
une du matin à paris la semaine dernière
vont parler du look de la cgt alors
quand on lisait l'article on
s'apercevait que c'était juste une
manchette de le journal y est ce que
vous pourriez pas que le look krasucki
c'est à dire le côté un peu voyeur comme
ça la casquette est ce qu'on va y pas
que ça peut décourager certaines
professions de des cadres des
professeurs de s'engager de de militer à
la cgt
ce que vous croyez pas vous donner à
l'essai était finalement un look un peu
trop paul hogan est essentiellement un
look aux locaux que je suis comme je
suis ensuite la cgt quand je ramène pas
à une personne n'y a ni à son allure on
a la tête qu'on a et non il ya l'image
qu'on fabrique rien à la réalité des
personnes et de l'organisation
vous me parliez de du matin de paris
c'était un titre incorrect il ne sera
donc on est paralysé la route égard sont
exprimés ça n'était pas innocent et
c'est n'est pas une affaire de justice
j'ai réagi en protestant
oui le matin de paris a approuvé une
protestation
je tiens à me faire respecter et à faire
respecter l'organisation que je
reprenant non pas pour en revenir à
votre question de la diversité des
salariés je veux savoir à présent passer
du monde du travail tel qu'il est je
pense que c'est plus pour empêcher une
catégorie sociale quand je me trouve
j'ai souvent l'occasion de rencontrer
des ingénieurs des cadres supérieurs des
techniciens bien sûr les scientifiques
je visite jeudi ce quiz
nous comprenons et ils n'ont pas
l'impression de parler à un extra
terrestre je vous arrête c'est positif
je vous donne trois minutes et vous
allez venir le convaincre de rentrer à
la cgt vous avez trois minutes
comme dit bout
vous êtes une salariée
il vous arrive il peut vous arriver
d'avoir besoin de défendre vos intérêts
de salariés salaires avancement sécurité
l'emploi dignité aussi vous avez besoin
d'être organisée
seul on peut vous arriver de vous
dézinguer l'importance et syndicale est
d'accord mais pourquoi la 60e j'y viens
mais d'abord d'abord l'idée c'est de se
regrouper
alors pourquoi le sait la cgt mais parce
que si tu aimes à un syndicat plus
combatif que la cgt plus proche des
préoccupations des gens tout nus ferme
dans les discussions avec des patrons il
allait la pizza est la pudeur de défaut
je n'ai en tout pas essayer de la
semaine s'ils n'aiment ne vous convient
pas et bien contribué à le faire comme
vous voudriez qu'ils soient mais ne
restez pas seul parce que comme salarié
vous êtes en faire et ce passionnant
s'il commençait à faire engager mes
salariés la série s'arrêterait pas mal
pour moi là bas je veux seulement quand
on me faut c'est que ceux-là je demande
une augmentation de même quand on entend
ça c'est comme un rêve c'est convaincant
cette fois ci alors maintenant je
voulais une question d'image et écoutez
moi j'aimais je veux dire moi je ne
cherche pas comme ça à convaincre le
ministère
je veux donner les charrs richir ouais
alors écoutez moi m'a fait partie des
gens qui pensaient que le bilan des pays
de l'est est globalement positif
vous avez participé en septembre 86 à
berlin-est à une réunion de la fsm s'est
un peu réconcilié un concours est le
onzième est un peu réconcilié avec eux
et vous vous êtes maintenant et des
vice-présidents de la fsl en compagnie
de roumains de bulgares de cech de
russes et d'allemands de l'est
aux yeux de beaucoup doté de beaucoup de
questions est ce que vous m'aurez
krasucki aujourd'hui vous vivriez dans
un pays de l'est avaient d'abord je suis
français oui bon alors moi j'aime bien
vivre henry d'accord sur tout alors
parce que ce genre de questions vous
voyez ça n'a pas beaucoup de sens à moi
je vis en france et je par contre j'ai
une certaine idée de comment on pourrait
vivre mieux en france et écrit des
revenus en france
c'est un peu se rapprocher des pays de
l'alba même pas du tout on peut pas au
sens de copier ce qui se fait dans tel
but à madrid notant qu'il s'agit il ya
certaines choses
* certaines choses m'intéressent c'est
peut-être souvent caractère fondamental
car je trouve qu'il ya des injustices et
des inégalités sociales
le système est bien ce sont énormes il
ya pas d un ministre et le dise il ya
aussi les catholiques qui disent que
tout le monde
alors je vais partager je pense donc je
considère que telle qu'elle est cette
société a besoin d'être changé et a fait
mais à la française ils ont une fonction
de notre histoire de la manière de vivre
des français et c'est tout à fait autre
chose bien mais mais vous ne me ferez
pas sous prétexte qu'on sait déjà qu'un
espoir de faire changer d'avis et tel ou
tel défaut renoncé à comprendre ce qui
se passe d'important dans ces pays date
ce qui s'y est passé là bas si je prends
l'union se dire si elle a fait il ya 70
ans c'est l'équivalent à notre siècle de
ce que la révolution française la
filiale ya deux chiens cancer
oui poser une question définitive ça
sera la dernière et j'aimerais qu'on me
répondiez le plus franchement possible
vous avez eu le malheur pendant la
guerre d'être déportés
aujourd'hui en urss on n'est pas sans
savoir qu'il existe des camps de
concentration comment pouvez vous serrer
la main de ces gens là vous savez quand
l'urss les juifs n'ont pas droit de
sortir du rss comment pouvez vous serrez
la main ce jour là comment pouvez-vous
me poser des questions il est un
journaliste aussi peu raisonnable parce
que non aujourd'hui ça existait mais
aujourd'hui en urss
il n'existe pas aujourd'hui non
aujourd'hui il y a parce qu'ils n'ont
pas eu non plus on peut de crise ont ils
ont un système pénitentiaire qui est
basé sur des camps de travail
ils disent que c'est pour une
rééducation mais ça concerne des gens
est prisonnier de droit commun ils n'ont
pas de prisonniers politiques
il y en a eu nous avons que vous dites
aujourd'hui à des dialyses nous avons
protesté
sinon est ce culturel sont en train de
régler ces messieurs et vous le savez
des réformes sur lui en union soviétique
en ce moment notamment sur la question
des droits de l'homme y compris sur la
liberté de circulation des juifs ou de
tout autre c'est qu'il est juif et c'est
mes jeux comme elle l'est refusent
qu'ils n'ont pas droit de sortir
justement je suis en train de vous dire
cette question puis deux années à
critiquer à discuter alors dire mais
pour pourquoi vous laissez pas ces gens
circuler sorti un cd aujourd'hui c'est
en cours de règlement vous pensez que
j'entends du bruit mais ces points
seulement
je pense pas que c'est parce que
seulement nous avons donné notre avis
nous avons joué un rôle est utile
justement à une époque où nous reprocher
de ne de ne pas crier nous avons dit
qu'il fallait publiquement quand c'était
nécessaire au lycée à bien c'est en
train de changer sérieusement et
personne ne conteste dans les milieux de
l'information j'ai grand jour à la une
je reprenais par votre question parce
que parce que c'est la vraie neige en
commun vos collègues en ce moment sont
en train de devenir prudent ou hécatombe
pour eux des corrections de ne rien
rater de 1h10 tube abonnez vous mettez
un pouce bleus